in this video today we are going to
discuss about the seven master slash
kaijus that are confirmed to have
appeared in godzilla singular point
while the godzilla earth anime series of
movies had
not such a good review it did however
have quite a fan following that love
the biggest godzilla incarnation of them
all godzilla's singular point is yet
another anime of the g-man
but here the monsters are quite
different and the backstory 2 is unique
this series although already out in
japan will be released worldwide in
netflix on the 24th of june
and that my friends is my birthday now
let's get down with this sickness
the first one godzilla well obviously
there would not be any godzilla flick
without the g-man himself right
godzilla appears on this anime in ways
that you have never thought of before
he has four forms and in the final
singular point godzilla has
a more monstrous appearance with a dark
charcoal colour
and white dorsal plates that have red
vein like characteristics flowing
through them
there are also a lot of jagged teeth in
the design
its neck and forearms contains several
osteodome-like structures similar to
those found on
crocodilians he sometimes seemed to
tower over buildings although his size
isn't officially stated
but he is definitely within the 80 meter
range with a very long tail
and the four forms of gods of the
singular point will be shown in
another video so stay tuned
number two rodan this iconic touhou
kaiju makes its return
in the series but not in a way that you
would expect it to be
it is not a gigantic monster that rivals
godzilla in size and strength
rhodan's juvenile version is a large red
pterosaur
with dark plated spikes on its breasts
retaining the character's main design
elements
however in terms of body dimensions this
rodan is far more akin to real-life
pterosaurs
it has a huge head and a structure
similar to
the extinct quetzalcoatlus and it walks
on its wings
it looks to be more of the size of a two
or three story building
so maybe around 20 to 30 feet tall
rodin's major form is
smaller than its juvenile form with an
angular appearance
a short tail and a pointed grey beak
with two rows of bottom teeth
and a twin nasal crest number three
anguirus
this kaiju makes its return to the fray
after a very long hiatus
anguirus was always a fan favorite and
the last time any trace of him was shown
was in king of the monsters
as a skeleton in one of godzilla's lairs
it has
a thick carapace on his back that is
totally covered in sharp spikes that
go all the way down to its tail its skin
is brown and coated in scales and its
back is covered in a thick carapace
that is totally covered in sharp spikes
that run all the way down
the carapace hangs over the back of the
creature it has a spherical body and
robust armored legs
akin to that of an ankylosaurus it also
has a crest that resembles that of the
triceratops on its head
while preserving the conventional design
number four manda manor similar to the
case of rhodan
seems to be a species rather than one
individual
given that three or four of them were
shown to inhabit the ocean
manda retains its long serpentine body
but its head appears to be
more closely resembling a goblin shark
crossed with a pit viper
than a dragon like the previous
incarnations it also has some traits
similar to a lobster
such as its armored carapace as well as
lobster-like tendrils which mimic
the barbells from manda's atrogan design
it also has a pair of mantis shrimp-like
forelimbs
and sea turtle-like hind limbs as well
as a fin resembling one of godzilla's
dorsal plains
it seems to be hundreds of feet long and
was hunted by an aquatic godzilla
number five salunga this is a new
monster introduced in singular point and
kind of resembles gabara and we all
thought it was him
and due to his monkey-like appearance
salunga is shown to have impressive
climbing skills able to scale
the rafters in his containment cell like
they were tree branches
salunga is covered in pebble green skin
with several brownish gold ridges on its
back
as well as his shoulders it has ties
claws and tails and
a silver underbelly it also has large
archery bow-like
horn-ons on its foreheads as well as a
row of forward-facing spikes
while he is of a reptilian nature his
anatomy is similar to a monkey
particularly a baboon number 6
kumonga yet another kaiju making a
return
with long pointy legs and what appears
to be megalon's horn
at the apex of her abdomen the kimono
resembles a cross between a spider
a crab and megalon they are a species
and they are dark green in hue
and have yellow stripes on them akumongo
have four
small blue eyes on their heads as well
as two
larger eyes on the size of its heads
each with two little antennas on top
kimonos are extremely agile showing when
jaguar tried to attack them only for
them to speed out of the way and attack
him
from all angles commoners can use the
sharp tips of their legs to stab their
prey
as well as their foes they are around 6
to 8 feet tall and around 10 to 20 feet
long
from side to side and number 7
jet jaguar maybe this last one isn't an
organic thailand or a monster but he is
definitely one of toho's most iconic
makers
jet jager makes a comeback in singular
point
it has a similar appearance in color
scheme to prior iterations as well as
the original signature grin
with ripped rubber connectors shielding
the joints perforated metal sheets
covering the cockpit and three-fingered
hands that appear
to be borrowed from industrial robots it
appears to be a mecca made crudely in a
garage to fend off smaller monsters
it is around 10 to 15 feet tall and one
of the smallest in the series
so we've come to the end of the video
let us know what you think and put it
down in the comment section below
and with that we end this video on the
seven masters of godzilla singular point
subscribe to be a part of the mind q
family and hit that bell button for
monster updates
till the next one take care fam